It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
And today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ruffians!
Good morning!
Thank you for joining us today for our 133rd episode!
BAU BAU!
130 seconds.
One hundred and thirty-two!
BAU BAU!
Well well, welcome to... It isn't the 133rd episode of FUWAMOCO Morning, but maybe the first!
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday!
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
It's hosted by us!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
Do you have your coffee already?
Coffee or orange juice?
Sometimes I have many teas.
Appetizer.
I hope that the food that you're making that you're going to eat from here on... Because you're going to have breakfast!
I hope that it makes it onto the plate and not onto the floor.
Good wishes all the way!
Well, if you dropped it, it would be disappointing, right?
Maybe there's something nasty that will help you pick it up?
Well, I feel like this is probably equally as disappointing as dropping your breakfast.
Let's take a look at it.
Another Pero Sighting.
Let's see.
Get it over with.
Yeah.
Then we can pick up the cereal.
Cereal.
Yeah, cause it's on the floor.
Okay!
De-den!
Oh!
Oh, from the garbage to the washing machine!
I guess it's a replacement?
I don't know, this is probably what Pero wants, right?
What do you think?
Ruffians!
Do you think we should put him on for a spin?
Yeah, he's getting a spin wash.
Well, that's up to you, Ruffians!
He needs a good wash.
Get the filth off him.
I don't think the washing machine, no washing machine is that good.
Turn it on!
Is he stuck?
He looks pretty comfy, but not stuck.
Do it.
Maybe I'll be slightly less nasty.
I'll chew, you know, bubbles.
Bubbles always make everybody happy, right?
He's just going for an intense bubble bath.
Morning!
Everybody likes bubble baths.
I don't know if they like it at this intensity.
Maybe not, but... Yeah, I don't know.
I feel like we should put him in for a spin!
Yes!
You know, cause the garbage compact, it doesn't really work for him.
He just goes... Right.
But... You know, this way it'll make him a little bit less nasty.
At least a little less stinky.
Yeah, but you know Pero, his tongue is really long and nasty, right?
But actually, that would work out well for him in this situation, because because it's so long, he doesn't really need to breathe as much, actually.
Breathe?
Yeah, it's kind of funny, you know, he huffs and puffs a lot, you know, so I think he'd enjoy that.
Yeah.
The only downside though, is that he'll become a nasty wet demon dog.
How is he gonna get all dry again, Ruffians?
I guess that's this Ruffian's duty next time.
Yes!
Well, we hope he doesn't ruin your clothes!
BAU BAU!
Hang dry.
Oh, you could by his ways.
Lots of different ways.
Oh, by the ears.
BAU BAU!
The dryer, of course.
That's really rude to the dryer, though.
Lots of thoughts.
If I was a writer, I'd be like, I'm quitting my job.
Then you just don't have a title anymore.
It's just a square box.
Square box!
Freebook.
Free.
BAU BAU!
Recently, Ruffians, you know, it seems like there's always something exciting going on.
And just yesterday, our senpai from hololive english prom just had their first anniversary!
BAU BAU!
Already one and a wonderful year since we promised formed all together.
What a big congratulations!
But they celebrated of course all together.
Looking over past memories and getting up to all kinds of silliness, you know.
Yeah, and you know they also announced some wonderful anniversary merch.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
They are now up in upcoming 3D Promise Musical!
BAU!
3D musical?
Oh my gosh.
What do you think it could be, Ruffians?
I just imagine like... I'm imagining cruelty senpai like... Stomping Bae-senpai through the chest with one of her legs and then Bae-senpai falling to the ground so dramatically and then doing a beautiful dance on the ground and then getting home.
Kind of like Utena.
Is this a musical?
Of course, they're singing at the same time too.
Maybe Senpai gets stomped to the chest.
Yeah.
Maybe Senpai's leg.
Like she's stomped to the chest with a leg.
I thought they sing in musicals.
They do violent things sometimes too, especially in the theater.
You hope it's a comedy?
I hope it's a comedy too!
Yeah!
I hope it won't!
No!
In theater, you know!
Yeah!
December 24th.
I know!
I love BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
I love you, Chachi!
We were just talking about Starbeam's...
Good morning!
BAU BAU!
But you know, it's gonna be a disappointment.
It's hard to wait, I wanna see it now!
I need to know which subplot gets dubbed.
I don't know, maybe I'm thinking of something more like Shakespeare.
Is that a musical?
I don't know, I'm not well versed in these kind of things I guess.
We'll have to see!
Yeah, but you know, we've seen some of Aki-senpai's musicals.
And it's such a cool concept!
You know, FUWAMOCO, we want to do one too!
Yeah!
It's on our Goals and Dreams list for debut!
But I don't know, I'm excited.
I want to know what the theme will be!
Maybe the theme will be... Drama!
The Broken Promise?
Broken Promise!
It says right there, The Broken Promise.
BAU BAU!
Nerissa's gonna be really excited.
We're all excited!
BAU BAU!
Suisei-senpai!
Yeah!
Suisei-senpai was on a TV show in Japan announcing the most popular songs of the now.
And not only was she just like, "oh, Hoshimachi Suisei, this is her song."
She was there to perform!
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
It was so cool!
It was so cool
We watched it!
Yeah!
Suisei-san was there!
It was an amazing performance.
She performed BIBBIDIBA first and then her brand new song by Natori.
Oh my, I still have it stuck in my head.
And you know all the other performers there, all the other idols that I've seen.
Yeah, I saw Suisei-san!
Oh my gosh!
The penlights and everything!
It was so cool.
Why, you know, seeing, you know, Suisei-senpai doing such amazing things, it really makes us want to work really hard so that maybe one day we can become big senpai too.
Although we definitely can't be.
Not like that, but.
We can't be.
I just, I just want to be amazing and talented as Suisei-senpai.
But we will do our best to become as fluffy and fuzzy, you know, the FUWAMOCO way.
Yes, so.
I think.
We ate cake with one and then we all danced Bibbidi-bob and I had a fork in my hand.
Deshita!
But maybe one day Moco-chan you won't have a fork in your hand, you'll have a mic in your hand.
Yeah!
When?
We ate cake and we danced Bibbidi-bob and I had a fork in my hand.
I wonder maybe if you have a microphone.
Yeah.
I don't have anything.
I had a fork in my hand.
Moco-chan, I have to ask.
Did you say... What?
You said we danced a bibidi-ba.
Did I?
I said we danced bibidi-ba.
Ruffians, let's all do a nice bibidi-ba all together, okay?
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO Congratulations!
Well, the last time, Ruffians, we shared with you some big news!
Big news that we ordered our received balls!
But there was actually a good reason because we had a little bit of motivation to order something else and then we figured that we should order balls.
So we did.
Ruffians, can you guess what maybe FUWAMOCO decided to order?
But give us some motivation to do that!
Cats!
That would be accurate if you could order cats anime figures!
We did it!
Oops!
We ordered some figures, but it was for the very good reason!
For the first time!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
I think it was just released recently so we have to get it right now!
And so we got Poruru onee-chan's denjouen.
Moco-chan, you're playing with it as we have breakfast.
What pose should I do?
What heart should I put in?
And not just that, we got Fubuki's denjouen!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Do you have display shelves?
Not in the slightest.
Any shelves.
No shelves.
There's no place to put them.
Figures first, shelves later.
And then we also got another have a good smile figure of a certain cat.
MCC has another friend, but the friend was out of stock.
And also, Hobuki-senpai's friends with this other cat.
And it kind of looks like a... Maybe that cat's usual friend got replaced and now it's kind of an interesting friendship.
Yeah, yeah.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
We are very happy that we are able to welcome Ai-senpai and speakers into our doghouse!
BAU BAU!
They said that we got wolf.
And Ruffians!
And Ruffians too.
BAU BAU!
Yeah, you know the true story, Ruffians.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Tofu bar?
Brown tofu bar.
What the heck is this?
Is it okay?
I was like, what am I looking at here?
Is this supposed to be with the rest of the tofu bars?
Black tofu, that's what you would think.
I thought maybe it was like, ah, squid related, squid ink.
Shokuban no.
No.
It was...
Dessert actually!
Tofu choco... What's the word?
Gato.
What?
Anymore!
FUWAMOCO!
Don't really like chocolate.
But I just thought we had to try it because it looks so silly.
Yeah.
Ew.
Was it ew?
Wasn't you at all?
Actually, it doesn't taste a thing like tofu.
I've been too scared, I haven't tried it.
It's very chocolatey, so it's like a... I feel like you should heat it up.
No.
That might make the tofu flavor come out.
I felt like for the gato chocolate name, I was like, this is that.
This is the French chocolate.
Yeah, like French for cake, I guess.
What kind of cake texture?
It was like a tofu.
No!
No tofu!
It was just like a cake.
A chocolate cake.
A very chocolatey cake.
Like a bunch.
It's not cake.
It's tofu.
Tofu bar da yo.
Chocolate's not good for dogs.
Ruffians!
We're not dogs!
We're demon dogs!
How many times do we have to go over this?
FUWAMOCO, we just don't really like chocolate.
We can't eat it.
If it tastes really chocolatey, it tastes really bad.
It was like... I'm just being silly.
Okay.
But it was a new discovery for sure.
I didn't know tofu could go to this kind of new level.
A new tofu world.
They are beautiful.
BAU BAU!
If you see Ruffians, please give it a try.
It's definitely a new discovery.
BAU BAU!
Konbini?
Konbini uteru?
Konbini moshikashite aru kamoshirenai.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
It's the middle of the week.
How are you doing?
Are you doing okay?
Do you need a little bit more head pats than usual?
Whatever we need.
Moco-chan puts out this and all the time for that, Moco-chan.
Yeah.
You doing your best?
You need a boost?
Well, when you need a boost, sometimes a little bit of a Pup Talk helps.
Oh!
Wow.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
Do you know what day of the week it is?
Go on!
That's pretty good you know.
Pup Talk Day!
I say yes!
FUWAMOCO!
Because this here is a Mococo Pup Talk!
And you're gonna hear it straight from me, Mococo!
Ruffians.
How has the week been?
Good?
A little bit rough?
No.
Sometimes things are like that.
I know you do your best, but sometimes things just won't go your way no matter how hard you try.
It's just how it is.
You know, no matter your best efforts, it can't be helped.
Sometimes the best thing to do is to just accept that.
But that's all you can do.
You can't do anything about the current results.
You just have to keep on moving forward and trying your best, okay?
Don't get disturbed.
Disturbed?
Don't get discouraged!
Okay!
You can do it!
I know you can.
Ganbatte desh!
Let's do our best!
BAU BAU!
You know, sometimes things just don't go the right way.
And it's best just to laugh.
Got it!
So, Ruffians, during those times, just remember FUWAMOCO's there, laughing together with you.
We have been doing something a lot lately.
FUWAMOCO.
Just keep watching on exactly!
FUWAMOCO!
FUWAMOCO
Ruffians, look at where you're sticking.
There are lots of gentle head parts, right?
Gentle.
Just for now, okay?
Okay!
The other corner should know it.
It's the one of braveness.
Braveness.
And... Excitement.
What's to come.
Because she's gonna be riding circles all around the place very soon.
Yeah.
That echoes the corn.
That's the echo in the corn!
It's the corn, you know.
The corn kind of makes everything a little bit more...
That dog sounded just like her little son.
Well, you know, she's super sweet, but she's a little bit down, so she has to wear this silly cone.
You know, head pads, it's a little bit harder to get them.
But despite everything, she's still ready to listen to what's all been bugging you.
She wants to cuddle, even though there's a big cone getting in the way.
Yeah, she would like to ask for a bite or two from your plate though.
I would recommend supporting this.
BAU BAU!
Let's take a look, Ruffians!
It's getting so nice and cool.
Beautiful and crisp.
Let's see what kind of walks we've been going on.
Today I went on a walk.
De-den!
Ducks!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Right in the line.
Right in the center.
Right.
Is that just us?
Do you feel that way, Ruffians?
Shoes.
They look like shoes.
Shiba shoes!
Shiba shiba shoes!
They just took off their shoe and left it there.
Right.
They just like, jumped in the water.
Yeah!
Free shoe!
Look at the shoe!
Yeah.
What?
Why are you making those faces, Ruffians?
This is normal.
It's normal.
Yeah.
They're very cute.
The water looks so nice and cool.
Now I'm just wondering what it'd be like to be a dog.
I have to ask Zubaru-senpai.
BAU BAU!
Let's take a look at our Question of the Day!
We have... De-den!
2000 years is a long time to be around.
Yes!
I'm sure you both have seen a lot of anime in that time.
What are some design tropes or aspects that you've seen slowly disappear over time?
For me, it's gotta be heaven.
Hair vents are wonderful.
There's so many.
Yeah.
You know, the Nogen has to breathe a little bit.
And you need hair vents for that.
Really?
My hair vents are bigger!
But to answer the question... Aspects maybe?
No?
I know I talk about them all the time, but main robots.
I miss the main robots so much.
Main what?
Robots!
Robots?
Main robots.
She misses the main robots, okay?
I don't need a big robot.
I need big robots!
I want them to be there for me.
No, it's to help me get across the lake!
It would help us!
I want her to be there to help me get home from school!
And then I'm gonna protect her memories at all costs!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
I think also just a general boy meets girl kind of you know.
Urusei Yatsura.
Oh My Goddess.
Yeah!
No, no, no, no!
Don't!
Magical girl.
Extraordinary girl comes into your life.
Yeah!
Right!
I missed that.
Yeah!
Doesn't count if it's a reboot.
Reboot?
Not a robot!
Reboot.
Yeah!
And other aspects.
Ah!
The little sister who's annoying and wants love!
And used to get away from me!
Right?
There hasn't been many of those recently, right?
Hai.
I miss that too.
Yeah.
Alright!
Also zettai ryouiki.
Morning deshita.
BAU BAU!
Why is zettai ryouiki not so common anymore?
Well, thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions.
Don't forget, FUWAMOCO Morning is something that we make together.
And I would like to ask you for more help.
Please use the hashtag, hashtag, FWMCMORNING.
Send us the walksie going on your questions.
I know you have lots of good questions.
We've been seeing a bunch in the marshmallow box too as they come in.
Also your Pero Sightings.
And your Doggie of the Day is okay.
Okay!
We're waiting, okay?
We're waiting!
BAU BAU!
Well, we have another stream coming up again.
Very soon here.
We have the day!
Seven days to die!
It's hololive English!
It's the first day!
The big event is starting!
Moco-chan!
The goal is to survive.
It says 7 days to die.
It makes it sound like you need to die, but it's to survive.
Let's survive.
I don't know.
I don't want to die.
I want to be like, oh!
Everybody in hololive English has died at least once.
FUWAMOCO is gonna be a survivor.
Okay?
Watch it happen, Ruffians.
Watch it happen!
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
And our schedule!
Our schedule coming up at 5am on Thursday morning PT.
We're gonna be having our first offline with Suwopatra!
We're gonna be answering some Mashimaro's questions!
And you know, we're just gonna have a really fun time together.
If you don't know who Suwopatra, she is
Amazing!
She's super cute!
Yeah!
Demon Goddess who wrote Lifetime Showdown!
And just amazing at ASMR and a bunch of different things!
Toy!
Games!
Natural games!
Yeah!
She's so talented!
We look up to her so much and we're so excited to be able to have a bunch of fun together!
We know it's a bit early in the morning!
But I'm sure it's gonna be fun so if you want to stop by, okay?
BAU BAU!
Moco-chan!
Did you notice?
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
We're only 10,000 subscribers away!
BAU BAU!
Thank you Abyss!
Only a few steps until one of our biggest goals here.
Thank you!
Let's continue to have lots of them because there's even more stuff coming up this week.
We have more 7 Days to Die, more FUWAMOCO Morning.
We also have a very
Special stream we're going to be a part of over on Marine-senpai's channel!
We're going to be participating in Houshou Marine's Brain Battle!
And we're going to become our own fluffy fuzzy version of Houshou Marine-Senchou-senpai's brain!
And you know we're going to solve some very deep personal problems.
Yes.
It's going to be chaos.
Please come and join!
That's also gonna be a 4AM PT on Sunday!
It'll be chaos.
Do what you can.
BAU BAU!
And then for the doggy pack, we're playing Fall Guys!
Please join us!
It's gonna be a lot of fun.
You never know what's gonna happen this week, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
We'll be looking forward to it!
We definitely are.
And for the Ruffians who are joining us through the archive today, here is your FUWAMOCO word.
It's...
BAU BAU!
Beautiful.
BAU BAU beautiful.
Ruffians are beautiful.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for another episode of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
GDCard!
BAU BAU!
Mifu!
Blue Autumn.
BAU BAU!
Sukeishin.
Max.
BAU BAU!
Dante.
Kinoaes.
BAU BAU!
Diego Von Lucas.
Forever Apart.
BAU BAU!
Fengshan.
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!